he is my uh buddy from the nfl network
nfl media group and also goes way back
in the day
walking on the wild side with dennis
rodman and with rodman front and center
and the last dance being something
that's taken up a ton of oxygen
in our sports room these days with no
live events and no live sports
i figured let's have the co-author of
walk on the wild side a man who was back
in the day with rodman and someone who
also knows what's going on in the nfl
today
my buddy michael silver how are you
michael i'm great rich how are you i'm
doing fine how did you get involved with
rodman
back in the day mike let's just jump
right into it with both feet
well i was hired by sports illustrated
in
late 1994 and we um
in 1995 we had just finished an
infamous media summit which as good as
the nfl media summits have been
in recent years this was a boondoggle of
epic proportions out in orlando and uh
jordan ended his retirement during that
and they actually you know sent rick
riley hastily out to
go work on that and it shuffled some
things and
i came home pretty dog tired my wife
wasn't loving me and i got a call that
said you got to get to la we want you to
do a story on dennis rodman
he was on the spurs they were getting
ready to close out the western
conference semis against the lakers at
the forum
and i kind of my first reaction was oh
man you're killing me but i i knew
it had the potential to be a good match
rodman was just getting
weird kind of overtly had been
involved with madonna recently and i
figured we'd either
really get along or not so much and
i i don't know i must be a little
twisted because we proceeded to go on a
four-day three-state odyssey with very
little sleep
a lot of pearl jam blasting gambling in
vegas
coaches yelling at him
then gm greg popovich yelling at him
and i wrote what turned out to be an si
cover story in real time at his house
after we'd had
a nice dinner at a gay bar um
then or i think dinner at a strip club
went to a gay bar
um he was in another room
with a stripper friend making some loud
noises and there were some exotic birds
all over the house
even louder and uh somehow i wrote that
thing and then
wrote the lead in the morning as more
zaniness ensued so
you know it was uh it was a blast and
then we proceeded to
spend a lot of time together in the next
few years and
it helped kind of kick kick off my si
career
and at one point we were on a plane rich
and
about day three of this and he looked at
me and he said you are bleeps
and i looked up and he said yeah man
after this everybody's going to be
boring i'm the most you know no one's
gonna be more open than me no one's
gonna be more fun than me and i
kind of laughed and thought yeah he
might be right but
we're gonna we're gonna enjoy this was
he right
yeah i mean in some sense senses he was
right i mean i i always
feel like i can bond with people and get
access and get
compelling stories and there are people
who obviously are
doing very serious important things that
you know you and i try to
to highlight and talk to but in terms of
living out loud and letting your freak
flag fly in the sports world
it was pretty significant and you know
in a much different time
and i and i don't know how much of it
was truly appreciated at the time
because of that but
you know he was a guy who felt like he
was weird inside and was afraid to let
that out for a long long time and
and he was afraid because he thought
he'd be reviled and mocked
and when he finally started to he was
shocked that so many people in society
who felt
marginalized or similarly
really warmed to him and celebrated him
and
felt like he had you know spoken for
them in a way that
that really touched him and a lot of
these people weren't basketball fans and
you know specifically the lgbtq
community
and uh you know the transgender
community specifically you know just he
was
um he was very openly kind of
you know sending the message that
these people were like us and totally
okay
and that also that you know maybe they
were being
uh you know unfairly looked upon
and i i i think that a lot of that kind
of got lost amid the noise and the
hysteria
and the fun and there was a lot of fun
but he was really
you know ahead of the curve on that mike
silver my compadre from nfl network nfl
media group reminiscing about his rodman
days uh when he was uh covering him for
sports illustrator and then wrote
a book with him walk on the wild side
why do that book after he was already as
bad as he wants to be
mike what where why do that well it's a
sad it's a sad story rich
no i so after that si
cover story came out which was the
iconic cover with rodman and the
zip up metallic tank top and
uh the bird on his shoulder and all that
um you know a a publisher approached me
and i approached dennis and we were
going to do it and
i had just got an si i really didn't
know what that would mean in terms of
time commitment and i was their new
football guy
literally rick tellender left a couple
months after i got there and
they wanted me to be the lead football
guy and and
i i didn't know what that meant either
but i knew that it was gonna
take a lot of work and this book was
going to have to get done timing wise
during that first season i was
full first full season i was covering in
95. so
you know i talked to my bosses we tried
to see if it was workable they felt like
it wasn't going to be workable on their
end
and i ended up helping them find
tim kuhn to do that book partly because
uh you know i i knew tim would crush it
and
he uh you know he hit out of the park it
was a
a phenomenal book and it worked out
amazingly and sold a ton and
you know i was obviously a little bummed
i didn't get to do it but
i knew the product was phenomenal and
then you know i was
i was pretty amazed that they then came
back to me and said hey we got a nice
deal for a sequel we want you to do it
and i'm thinking
you know i mean tim tim did a pretty
good job on that first one i totally get
it but
it was amazing um the discussion to have
the
to whether we were going to do the
second book together literally it went
like this dwight manley's then agent
said
by now he's on the bulls they're playing
the sonics
in that's a team in seattle for you
supersonics uh in game one of the 1996
nba finals and um so dwight says listen
just fly to chicago
go to the game and we'll you know you
said you know we're all going to go out
afterwards we'll drink all night we'll
do our thing and then
you know the next day at breakfast we
can nail this down
so i just flew to chicago and i didn't
know where i was sitting who i was
sitting with and
you know i grew up with steve kerr so i
was already feeling
you know pretty excited about the the 96
bulls i knew jed bushler through steve
and you know now of course
dennis is on the team and uh you know
jordan's back in the finals it's a
pretty cool scene
and so i go to pick up my ticket and
it's courtside
okay cool wonder who i'm sitting with uh
a guy comes and sits next to me and he's
like hey i'm jeff
i'm like oh hey jeff totally cool chill
dude i'm like oh it's jeff amen from
pearl jam of course nice sweet
big sonic fan so that was fun um
so i i proceeded to watch
that epic game jordan going up against
gary payton and
at all with the basis from
one of my favorite bands of all time and
then we all went out that night
uh there was this short guy who probably
hadn't showered in a while
a little skittish at the time hanging
out with us oh there's eddie vedra cool
and you know really that kind of stuff
wasn't uncommon going out with rodman
although
you know eddie vetter was a pretty big
deal of course but
uh you know there was a there was a big
fun scene with people from all walks of
life
and i i think you know
in those days that's why rodman
you know really felt uh so invigorated
and
and so emboldened to to just let it fly
because he wasn't
seeing it as just basketball and and you
know i have plenty of conversations with
him where i said
dude rebounding like i know you i know
you think you're a movie star i know you
think it's bigger than all this but
you gotta stay great at the one thing
that you're
the best at you know don't forget and uh
you know
but as things kind of went on that scene
changed and
more and more people around him i felt
were
just egging him on to be dennis rodman
the freak show and
there were fewer people who came into
that scene as
legitimate entities who did their own
thing and
i think it got harder and harder for him
that way
and um you know i'm i'm proud of him for
for persevering and and hanging tough
and and
still being you know still being in the
mix and uh he's definitely not a perfect
guy but
he's he's tried very hard to not let it
all collapse
mike silver here on the rich eisen show
so you're watching the last dance i
imagine and you see the rodman episode
and uh yeah carmen electro uh who i'm
sure you crossed paths with back in the
day then
uh uh right in the middle of the rodman
orbit
when the last dance was uh was actually
being played
um did you learn anything what were your
thoughts when you watched that
i it was interesting you know i i was
all over the rodman 30 for 30 and
that was really cool and uh so i kind of
went into the last dance i hadn't been
interviewed and i'm wondering you know
am i going to turn up in any of the
footage so first of all the vegas trip
which i kind of remember during that
season that that last season in chicago
i immediately started getting texts from
some people like hey were you on that
trip
and i kind of had to go wait was that
i don't think i was on that one but
there were a few right
i'm trying to you know i'm looking at
the timing like was it during the
football season i'd
probably not but you know it was kind of
weird not to remember that it was such a
blur and then
i just um i guess i'm amazed that
there's so little footage
that has surfaced and i know it was a
different era
thank god without cell phone cameras and
and all that but
you know we were pretty conspicuous
you know when we would go out in chicago
for example we would
have dinner in front of everybody we
would go to crowbar a
pulsating club full of you know
thousand plus people and you know no
vip room no you know we were right there
in the middle of everything all the time
it was packed and you had to stay tight
to like move around when we'd go to the
next place but
it was no secret and um he was very
predictable that you know he had about
five places he ate dinner he had a
couple places he ate lunch and
you know a few clubs he went out to a
gay bar
like it wasn't you know in a strip club
like it wasn't
unpredictable where he'd be and it
wasn't a secret
and um it just amazes me
i guess it's probably a good thing but
it just amazes me that there's not more
footage of what we were doing i remember
vividly we were at the mirage in vegas
where rodman used to go until i think he
was
banned at one point after a drunken
incident
i think leaving las vegas style but uh
um we're at the mirage and we're playing
craps
out in the middle of everything and
random people are
coming by and being part of the table
and dennis is talking to everyone and uh
it was you know as overt
of a celebrity scene as you'll ever see
uh
and i remember dennis at one point went
to the bathroom and he kind of pointed
to this
little room in the middle of everything
little
cordoned off area kind of half room and
there were a couple tables in there and
he said see that
he said that's where michael goes when
he comes here you know he
it's just him and the dealer alone
playing cards
in that room and nobody can get in and i
just
said you know that doesn't look very fun
he said no you know i
i don't see how it could be and just you
know such a different approach now
and i don't want to compare the two
michael jordan was a more massive
celebrity
uh and rightfully so we're talking about
you know
one of the most significant athletes in
the history of all sports
and but dennis was
you know dennis was the closest thing to
that
in sports at that time just because of
the
the public theater and the the weirdness
and the
the uh the loudness of it all so uh it
was
it was just such a divergent approach so
i guess
uh my question for you mike is what was
your interaction with jordan at all i
mean did jordan look at you
like you were an enabler or an
interloper or
because how does it it's amazing they
won foot basketball games
at the clip that they did with
everything that's going on i mean
i know we're hearing about what a rock
scene it was
but this truly was a a rock
star setting for
the nba and so how did jordan view you
uh take me in into that part mike i i
don't think he was thrilled to
not i don't i don't think it was
personal but i just think i was just
another guy that
you know was around dennis and doing
stuff with dennis and
you know rolling in to the practice
facility with dennis at
night in the morning when he probably
hadn't slept much and
um i don't i wouldn't say enabler but
you know just just part of the show
um although i will say this you know i
jordan knew
that he for the most part could control
dennis in all things basketball and you
know you see
that in the show and and there's no way
it would have
worked otherwise because david robinson
wasn't controlling dennis right at that
point
and certainly after he left the bulls he
was
you know more wayward but jordan was
still jordan so i mean but it is
really significant right like think how
would peyton manning look at me if i
were
rolling into the colts or broncos
orbit during those heyday times with
dennis with a football player living
like dennis rodman i mean you know
he probably would want to rip my throat
out deep inside so
yeah and you know i don't i mean i had
great interactions with jordan it was
fine i mean he was
you know it reminded me a lot of jerry
rice i came in
covering the 49ers in the you know late
80 or
89 and then the early 90s and that was
as close to a rock star
situation for a football team at that
point with joe montana
and jerry rice and ronnie lott and and
the ostentatious and
it was amazing so you know jerry rice to
me
was um so maniacally driven
and humorless and had to win everything
all the time
and i was around him every day and you
know we
got along great we had our ups and downs
we had some bad moments where you know
but
he was he was not a joy to be around it
was
relent unrelenting and it it
wore on everybody but it also made sense
to me that he was the
absolute best ever to do it because
that's what you want it would
would have bummed me out of some guy who
didn't seem to try that hard or didn't
seem to care that much was also
the greatest like at least this guy was
insufferable but it
led to something and and i think that's
how
it was with michael and you know
i i remember when sports illustrated
sent me out um
in the 97 96-97 season so the spring of
97
uh to do a story on steve kerr we had
been high school writing partners and
um you know now here he was and here i
was
and it was you know it was it was a cool
story so
um my wife and i and our newborn
daughter who's now
23 flew out there and stayed with
stephen margot
and and their young family and uh spent
a bunch of days out there and it was
awesome and you know steve had joined
the team the year
or steve had been on the team and jordan
had come back the year before and they
famously
got into a fight like at the first
practice and jordan punched him in the
face and
uh it was you know they ended up
becoming
close and steve hit the game-winning
shot in the nba finals it was awesome so
you know he's kind of really for the
first time laying that whole scene out
for me and you know he said dude he said
you know i'm sitting in practice and i
can tell jordan doesn't like me or he's
mad he's not into me and he's provoking
me and finally
he's about to you know he pushes me and
i he said i got two choices
and they're not good choices i can you
know
wuss out and be basically
you know consigned as as you know
consigned to the garbage bin in his eyes
and
my teammate's eyes forever or i can
fight michael jordan and so he fought
michael jordan and
and lost and uh you know and lived
through it but i i remember
at one point steve's son nick who is now
uh you know a couple years older than my
daughter but
he was very young and i said uh you know
he said yeah nick and
you know michael's kids shoot around
sometimes and you know
before practice and i said well let me
ask you a question i said if you
played michael jordan and horse and you
beat him could you like laugh about it
the next day or make a comment about it
and steve like looked at me dead serious
and he was like
no way no chance and i said what if
nick beat you know beat michael's son uh
what could could you make a joke about
that he's like
absolutely not no so i mean i i just
i hope people appreciate that the most
about jordan that it
was you know sure he could be funny and
charming and
he had his outside interest but it was
relentless
and you know i i don't think it's that
unlike
your bradys and your mannings and your
races but
uh you know there's a method to the
to the success so a few minutes i have
left with you mike silver
um when was the last time you spoke to
rodman what's your relationship like
with him
now it's good it's it's sporadic
uh you know it's funny i forgot the last
time i talked to him on the phone
uh was probably i don't know maybe about
nine months ago or so but i for
you always forget that rodman robin's
way of ending phone conversations
is that he decides at some point in the
conversation that it's over and hangs up
with zero warning really and you know i
used to like kind of factor that into
the process but you know when you don't
talk to him as much
uh you know it always catches you off
guard and uh
you know one thing that was fun is that
uh you know and
people don't understand like the
sensitivity sometimes like he's
you know he he wants to please when he
he's got a great bs detector so if he
thinks you're full of it he
tunes out but if he's someone if you're
someone that he
wants to you know connect with he he's
you know there's kind of a sweetness
about him that uh
you know i think some people miss so uh
as the warriors
started getting really good you know he
and i talked a couple times about
him showing up to a game or both of us
go into one of the finals games maybe on
the road and
uh you know we we tried to kind of
connect that a couple of times
but at one point he called me and my
daughter
natalie was in the car and i think i put
her on speaker and there's this
photo i posted recently from that same
trip i referenced
to chicago to do the story with steve
where he's walking out he
he emerges from the locker room he's
wearing this top with
gold sequins and all this stuff and
she's kind of pulling at his top
she's you know six months old mesmerized
by the
shininess and he's literally trying to
hand her a can of beer
uh for laughs but you know it's one of
the outside photographers took the shot
it's a great shot
so you know he started talking to
natalie and got kind of emotional and
you know
we took him way back well
um natalie it turned out went to cal and
maddie kerr steve's daughter was a
volleyball star there a year ahead of
her and they
they became friends as adults and
they were at a party one night and
i jokingly flipped off the camera
and sent me the picture and i
i think maddie actually sent me the
picture and so at one point i sent it to
dennis
uh like after we had spoken just to kind
of go hey look dude it's
little maddie and little natalie and he
called me as soon as i said it kind of
all upset
and he thought they were flipping him
off and wanted to know like what
happened and i was like no no no no it's
it was it was a joke they're flipping me
off and i kind of had to talk them down
so uh you know i i really listen i'm
really touched by some of the things he
did for me
at the time i was a young sports
illustrated writer um
i wrote that cover story there were some
outrageous
quotes in there and and you know subject
matter
that was not generally talked about in
s.i
he went on david letterman right
afterwards i know he had been advised by
someone very close to him to deny
everything in the story subsequently
that that was the best strategy
and david letterman who was the biggest
thing in the world back then asked him
point blank
twice held up the magazine he said does
this accurately represent you
you know did you say these things that
both times he just
unflinchingly said absolutely it was a
great story
i love it and so you know i'll always
remember that when the heat really got
turned up
uh he stayed true to uh the process and
uh
you know he frustrates the heck out of
me like
some like he does a lot of people like i
would liken it to
it's like your best friend when you're
ten it's the greatest thing but
sometimes you need to have
an emotionally developed conversation
and you want to
strangle him but lovingly so so i i got
nothing but love for dennis and
uh i uh you know he's a work in progress
but
uh he's done a lot of cool things
perfect gotta ask the poll question as
we end and by the way i will say goodbye
i'm not just going to hang up on you
rodman style
that would have been cool oh yeah no no
i know i know it would have been good
for the joke but i i just still can't do
that
you know i'm a jewish goodbye guy you
know i mean
rodman's the exact opposite obviously uh
so ask the poll question of michael
silver that's at rich eisenhower for
people to vote on right yeah mike
which last dance style doc would you
want to see next
one about the brady belichick patriots
the 90s cowboys or the shaq kobe lakers
i'm going off the board i'm going 80s
and early 90s niners because then
i could be all over it and i would also
like to
uh i would also like to pour some liquor
out for
someone near and dear to rich in my
heart uh fictional
carl the jets fan from curb who never
got a chance
okay so the 80 should we add the 80s 90s
niners just real quick
uh michael so give me some what would be
the beats
to use the i guess phrase well i could
yeah it's gonna take too long but let me
just say this the people freaking out
because the packers drafted jordan love
and how's that gonna work with aaron
rodgers
steve young and joe montana were on the
same team for six
years there were times where they
alternated starts there was a game where
young played the first half and montana
played the second half just to see what
would happen
and they did not get along and it was
insane and
they're both first ballot hall of famers
and
people have no idea then bill walsh was
in the middle of it right and
and there's was in the middle of it i
was in the middle of it it was
awesome uh and well very quickly
steve young tells this great story where
he says to aaron rodgers
after rogers 2010 mvp season
the next year they're talking about it
and aaron's telling them about the whole
season and steve says oh yeah where was
brett during that and
aaron goes huh he goes where was brett
he's like uh
i don't know mississippi and steve goes
yeah
when i had my first mvp season joe was
on the sidelines
staring at me i mean people uh
people would be amazed by some of the
things that
that co you know some of the coexistence
that had to happen back in the day and
now your fail mary friend is in the role
of farf
isn't that amazing when it comes down it
is
it is i i am mandated i am mandated ask
i know we've been talking for a while
and i don't know if you have
anything to do else on this wednesday
but oh i'm good okay
what do you think how do you think
rogers is reacting to this
uh it is a great question i have not
directly spoken to him
um i believe that if he's upset inside
he's
very mindful of the optics and is
playing it off well but i don't know
you know i i think it clearly was a move
by management i think the more
um there's a chance that and and i would
advise management to play it this way
too there's a chance that it can be
coaches and rogers against the man and
that's probably the the best thing short
term for the organization if that's how
it goes and i don't think that would be
inaccurate but
i think the opportunity cost is more of
the issue than
the young guy on the roster who could
theoretically replace him
aaron rodgers knows he's the best
quarterback there and will be
and he's not worried so much about that
i think i think
it's what could they have done with that
pick and what do they do with the
subsequent picks and
you can understand how that would be
frustrating well i mean you know farv
came on this show one week ago on this
very day
and and and and termed that opportunity
cost is at burn bridge
that's how he termed that opportunity
cost said that it was gonna rear its
ugly
head the uh you call it opportunity cost
he called it
uh something that would definitely get
the wheels turning in rogers head
that will wind up with rogers wearing a
different uniform
a la brady manning and everybody else uh
from that
i guess i mean error i would not i would
not discount anything that brett says
about the subject a because he and aaron
have a good relationship now
and i and i know they talked as brett
said and b
because uh very few people have lived
those things but brett is one of them
and i've seen it happen with montana
i've seen it happen with
farv i saw mourinho basically told
you're done
you know and he had to decide whether to
go to the steelers or retire
see troy aikman be told you're done and
you can go somewhere else or retire
uh steve young you know was probably at
the end of line if he decided to come
back
and peyton manning uh you know it's and
now brady
a little different but yeah it's um
you know it's never easy it's never
smooth it's never seamless the closest
we got to that was elway with the
storybook walk off
second consecutive super bowl win but
organizationally they
they really paid a price they had a very
tumultuous
uh you know aftermath so uh
you know i i get why the packers will be
looking ahead i've heard some amazing
things about jordan love i think aaron
as long as the kid's not entitled which
i don't believe he will be from what
i've heard
i think aaron will treat him fine and i
think
uh in the short term he'll be motivated
even more or as much as and not more but
you know he'll be locked in as much as
he's ever been
but uh you know i don't discount
anything brett says about that because
they can have a conversation on a much
different level than any of us can
mike you're the man appreciate it uh are
you part of this uh scheduled release
show
tomorrow or uh or you just i'll be i
will be watching you
um i you know the reshuffling of the
cards
you i've been fortunate enough to be in
that room with you when it happened
i i think it's one of your you know i i
i don't think it's as
easy of an endeavor as it looks and uh
it always you know i when you're there
to carry it it always feels good but
i'm excited to watch you guys you know
we're not as
you know i'm sure most of your
viewers and listeners know that as a
network we're not
operational the way we normally would be
and we're obviously
contending with this unique situation
like everybody else but you know i think
what we've been able to do has been kind
of uplifting just
you know for for those of us who know
how tough it is to
to do this stuff uh you know we're we're
trying hard to provide a diversion
for for everybody and uh
you know i'm excited to watch what you
guys have going appreciate it mike i'm
just as good as i want to be that's all
you can hang up on me now all right
there you go hang up on him
that's michael silver
[Laughter]
mike thank you